this is Startalk okay so this is
somebody who wants to know about the
atmosphere and the gravity on Mars I
love the way that Steven Matt low
phrases this question somewhat inventive
him over which which is this came over
Facebook mhm he says okay Neil when the
New York Yankees play a road series
against the Mars cosmos how big will the
outfield have to be to prevent everybody
from hitting home runs also will the
pitcher throw faster in the atmosphere
or slower and will he or she skies very
liberal eyes got a female pitcher in the
major league mm-hmm interstellar uh to
planetary entered interplanetary night
understood interplanetary baseball
league will will he or she be able to
throw a curve ball and he um take it
back Steven is coming from Livingston
Montana Livingston Montana yes yes flat
country now here's something I never
seen a mountain in his life that's
what's called Montana so I was in
Montana recently I gave a talk in
Bozeman Montana oh really
yep six thousand people yeah showed up
for it
nice I don't know that many people lived
in my I think you had the entire state
to be a and by the way I was joking
about mountains because there are
mountains in much that's why it's called
mom and said mom that's Big Sky they
just got its Big Sky look at the amount
but uh go ahead uh it's so here's this
question how I got the question number
you read it I got it
I'm good memory excuse me I have an
awesome memory for three minutes ago I
know so so um a couple of things don't
change and other things do okay
the pitcher does not throw faster
because that's just their
musculoskeletal capacity to do so all
right the ball will not slow down as
much between release of the
fingertip and crossing home plate
because the air is thinner and there is
air resistance to the ball right that
slows it down I don't know it may be ten
miles an hour
whatever it is five miles an hour it's
not traveling for very long so it but it
will slow down a little bit it does that
in the majors it will do that on Mars
but it will slow down by a little bit
less a little bit look that's not the
major thing going on here the Martian
atmosphere is very thin it's like 1% of
our thickness and it's the air the
movement of the ball through the air
that enables it to curve right so curve
balls would be very hard on Mars because
you don't have the air or the thickness
of the air for those those what do they
call stitches stitches yes right that
would definitely go stitches on the
balls this is the coarseness it respects
the constitute or the bobble stitches
but you know that's what's causing that
rotation well it assists it even if it
didn't have stitches you still have some
you could still move it well really oh
yeah
but the stitches help it they're not
without the thickness of the air you
can't get that movement you don't get as
much movement okay yeah yeah yeah you
don't get as much move it now it is
windy on Mars so you could throw an
awesome knuckleball now his knuckle
balls don't rotate and so they're not
stable moving through the air right
rotating things are stabilized you know
that's why footballs
rotating for example is stable pinning
spinning okay so a knuckleball does not
spin therefore it is susceptible to any
possible puff of air that comes across
the side you could use a Wendy de
knuckleball to create the the the effect
of a curveball
well yeah but it'll it'll curve in a way
that you can't predict and that's why
catchers are always dropping knuckle
balls but they don't know where the hell
they do you know the ball is jiggling
and wiggling and it comes in and so the
number of passed balls past knuckle
balls by a by a catcher is huge relative
to other pitches a surprise box surprise
ball for everybody right even the
pitcher a curveball the catcher calls
for the curveball so there nobody knows
what he's doing
where it's coming so so those are not
love this is what I love about you and I
mean this I swear to God
see that this is what's great we're
talking about baseball on Mars but yet
you know all this crap about baseball
well it's how does this happen
no you know what it is it's not what I
mean by I like who I'm I'm a red-blooded
American I like me some baseball and hot
dogs okay an apple pie all right you
just start there okay so now the rest of
it it's just because I go to baseball
game and I'm curious about it
like I just ask questions of the game
and of myself relevant to the game
that's you
so for example I say to myself suppose
you're hit by a pitch on ball four right
you want to be able to go to second base
right exactly
I'm just saying it true I'm just saying
you know that makes sense we think about
I'm disarmed these are kind of questions
I asked about the game that's very fun
yes
so now we got to get that rule in
baseball that's awesome okay so now how
far how big a stadium would you have to
make Martian gravity is about 40 percent
of Earth's gravity okay
so if you weigh a hundred pounds on
earth you weigh 40 pounds about
thirty-eight pounds on Mars that's so
200 pounds you weigh 80 pounds which is
great because the muscles that you have
for carrying a 200-pound body will now
be operating in an 80 pound body so
you'll be able to jump higher okay yeah
well yeah so there's so maybe you'd make
the infield a little bigger because
you'd be leaping you know you'd have to
sort of adjust that right there be some
trial and error on rest to get the ideal
field size now when you hit a homerun
the ball is doing two things it's going
forward and it's going upwards right
okay and then if fish is going upwards
and then it starts coming downwards
while it's still going forwards right
each of those have a different effect
okay how far you how fast you can hit
the thing going forward has nothing to
do with being on Mars okay that's just
how fast did you swing right that's your
that's your swing strength it's your
swing strength now the Mars the ball
going up okay the same force will have
the ball go higher correct than on earth
which means it will travel farther
simply because it'll go higher
right alright and so you got to do the
man I haven't done the math on that so
yeah you if I were to guess you know
make it 40 percent bigger I mean just as
is a general rule it's a first at first
and probably if I do the math there are
some adjustments in there so a 400 dead
center field of 40 percent greater than
that would be a hundred and sixty more
feet and is that right if we're 2160
more feet so it'll be five hundred and
sixty feet dead center right just to
recreate the same eight design who ever
thought of a home run now now now
that means outfield is huge right which
means you got to have some fast
outfielders that is true you might have
to add two more outfielders to it that's
because that is fans out from home plate
right so if you if it's if it's 560 dead
center you know you're you gonna be
missing a lot of balls we can be like
Little League you had a fourth outfield
it might be two more out there did
that's amazing and a shoestring catch
would be awesome because you would jump
and you just keep going just keep sadly
just out of the stadium you into the
locker room what a catch any send the
showers son that's fantastic man so
Steven what a fascinating question there
you go that was great great great great
stuff alright let's um by the way I
don't know if I call in the Martian
cosmos why not call him like the Martian
there's got to be a better name for than
just cosmos plus you know finally the
World Series would apply to something
other than not that some states um the
Mars reds heads that we have the
Cincinnati Reds yeah about the Mars red
bars are much more justifiable array
exactly right that you don't wear the
red color comes from its comes from rust
on the Martian surface is that just why
iron iron on occasion oxidized iron yeah
yeah so the Mars Reds would be good
yeah the Mars rats there you go yeah
can't wait to buy tickets to that game
okay
bring oxygen bro yeah exactly
this is Startalk